There were individuals, there were
children that were torn from the arms of
their mothers. They were thrown over a
cliff.
>> There was another account of a um a cave
whereby they built a fire at the
entrance of it. And there were 3,000
individuals in those caves. About 400
infants were found in the stifled in the
arms of their mothers. And it was the
mountain was later nicknamed Chappelleu
for the great number of hats found
nearby on sticks from so many men who
were slain.
>> So they built the fire so the smoke
would go into the cave and suffocate
them.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow. The old ensees along with many many
other reformers during that time
believed that the papacy was the
antichrist.
>> Mhm. So what are the large book and the
large map on our table? James, you're
you're the guest here. So, I'm assuming
you have something to do with this.
James from
>> Biblical Hope. Yes, if I remember right.
Yeah. You've been on the show a few
times, but for those that are new, James
from Biblical Hope. He's going to tell
us what in the world are we looking at,
cuz some of it I don't think I can read.
>> Yeah. So, these are very old. Um, you're
looking at some documents here from the
17th century.
>> Uh, so it's old.
>> Yeah. 167172.
And, um, we've got a map right here. And
we've got some important statements in
this book that speak about some
interesting persecution that some
Christians faced way back hundreds and
hundreds of years ago. And it fits the
description of the woman that fled into
the wilderness that Revelation talks
about.
>> Okay.
>> And so we got to take a look at that
today.
>> So So this is from 1780. You said
>> 16 1670s.
Okay. And it's actually published by
these two books are written by Jesuits.
And it details the history of councils
and canons which are the decrees of Rome
in her councils going back hundreds and
hundreds of years. The first edition
begins you know way back probably I
believe it's first 2 century. So I think
the reason why this matters is because
you know God had a group of faithful
people throughout the time throughout
all of the years. And when you
understand prophecy, Revelation 13,
Revelation 17,
>> then this kind of persecution that this
group faced is going to happen again to
Christians. And God's going to have a
specific group again that's going to be
faithful. But it's not the majority,
it's the small minority. So the sad
reality is this group is today I mean
the the weldencies of today are not the
same as was this group back in the 12th
century
>> and you know to provide evidence of that
let's take a look at some of the events
that are taking place within the wen
seas today
>> in his last day in the city of Turin
Pope Francis made history by visiting a
waldeneian church it's the first time a
pope visits an evangelical church of
that particular denomination. In doing
so, he received the warm welcome
The Pope got to know this church well in
Argentina with about 30,000 faithful
worldwide. It's quite small.
>> So guys, it's a small church, but this
was the first time that they had the
pope come in and that's a definite
change from the welden seas of, you
know, hundreds of years ago.
>> Yeah. Because the
papal power persecuted them to the point
where they were killing them. Exactly.
Which drives a wedge between people
>> and the the oldenesis along with many
many other reformers during the time
believed that the papacy was the
antichrist.
>> Um which we have a whole video on if
anybody wants to watch that from just
the scriptures how that's defined and
how you there's no other institution or
person or whatever that can fits the
bill for that. But yeah, many of them
believe that during the time which has
kind of become lost nowadays among
Christians
>> and because they were persecuted
quite heavily. You know, you were
mentioning that there's not a lot in
books like this because history is
written by the quote unquote winners,
right? The ones that survive.
>> And so it's written from their
perspective. And so even when you're
digging through, you're not going to
find a favorable
>> account of Waldenzians, you know,
>> you know, um, one of the things that
that I think u history history books try
and do to kind of silence that a little
bit in some ways is they link the name
Walden to Peter Waldo. Mhm.
>> And you know, Peter Waldo was this
merchant back in the 12th century, rich
merchant who kind of sold off all of his
goods to go and do mission work in the
valleys. And a lot of people think that,
well, that's why they're called
Waldenzians. But the problem with that
is is that there's quite a lot of
evidence from the time period suggests
that's not why they were called
Waldenians.
>> So here's Bernard, the abbot of
Clarevou, and one of the things that he
said is they were called Waldenes.
Undoubtedly it is dense in the valley
because they are enveloped in deep and
thick darkness of error. So valleys
valley denses or the dense valleys with
which they lived or the area region
which they lived that was why they were
called walden seas. So it it gives a
clue that maybe these people living in
the valley were much older than Peter
Waldo himself
>> and maybe this stretched way way way
back. So to give some more evidence of
that, here's the 12th century canon uh
four from the council of tours. In the
parts of Tulouise, a condemned heresy
arose long ago which spreading gradually
like a cancer to the neighboring places
through Gaskin and other provinces has
already infected the greatest number.
And actually this quote where you see in
partus tulles damn heresis durum emerit
that is actually right here in this
book.
>> Wow. And so you can see evidence in the
12th century that they're talking about
this group that has existed for much
longer much longer than the history
books of today suggest.
>> So kind of going on like they were a
formulated people group or church or
whatever and and they had you know
they're kind of grouped together for
many centuries.
>> Yeah. Yeah. There was a movement that
was in those valleys that stretched all
the way back and you know the sinnote of
Lavau you have evidence of that where
the um there was a statement made that
it was a pestilential heresy of ancient
origin.
>> So so did they break off because they
disagreed with the pope way back then?
>> Yeah, actually there's evidence of that
right here. Rearius Sako this inquisitor
said that you know some said that in one
of the reasons he said that the Waldenas
were so dangerous he gave three reasons
first because it is older some say that
has existed from the time of Sylvester
and other from others from the time of
the apostles second because it is more
general for there's scarcely any country
where the sect does not so it was very
widespread actually
>> and the third because while all other
sects excite the abhorance by the
hearers by the outrageousness of their
blasphemies against God. The Leonists
were these wildies had a great
appearance of piety. For they believed
all things concerning God which are
contained in the creed. Rightly only
they blasphemed the Roman church which
blasphemy a great multitude of the leoty
are easily induced to believe. So, um,
there was evidence here that they
stretched back. There was individuals
testifying that they stretched back not
only to this time of Sylvester, but of
the time of the apostles. And
>> how far back does Sylvester go?
>> Well, Sylvester, you're looking back to,
you know, third or fourth century. And
what I find interesting about Sylvester
is Sylvester was the pope that allegedly
received the donation of Constantine,
establishing papal supremacy, which was
a forgery. M
>> so Sylvester was this one that was you
know invested with this authority at
least in Roman lore. Uh you know a lot
of them thought that the donation was
real until later on it was demonstrated
to be a forgery. But the Waldenes went
back they said some said to the time of
Sylvester but others from the time of
the apostles.
>> What's the document on the left there?
>> So the left uh right here this is Lucas
Tudencis Episcopy. contains the um an
excerpt of Reineria Sako's work, but it
was actually um this particular book you
can actually find there was a um a
Jesuit by the name of Jacob Gretzer.
>> Yeah, there he is right there. Yakobo
Gretzer. So, he's he's a Jesuit actually
and he's citing this 12th century
inquisitor Ria Sako. Now I have some of
Reeria Sako's actual documents from the
Vatican digital library where you can
see the same thing asserted right here.
They say that the church of Christ
subsisted in the bishops and other
prellets down to the time of the blessed
Sylvester and in him it fell away until
they themselves restored it. So there's
multiple versions of of this document.
You can find a sumocontra cathari but
also sumocontraaldes
and Jacob Gretzer has the the
sumocontraaldes. I haven't yet located
the older manuscript for that but um but
you can find those works available.
>> IHS goes all the way back to there. If
that document that documents from what
century
>> which one?
>> The one you showed on the left of the
screen.
>> Yes. So this one's from 1613 right here.
Yeah. And then this one right here um
goes back much farther. I'm not sure the
precise date, but you can look up
vat.lap. 3978 right there. Um, and then
also regg.lap.428 right down there at
the bottom. And you can see right here
where he states they assert that there
were always some who feared God and were
saved. Also, they say that infants are
saved without baptism. So, this provides
evidence that these people were
anabaptist in their origins and they
rejected infant baptism.
>> We were just talking about that the
other day. Yeah. What so can you define
Anna baptism the word what does it mean?
>> Yeah. So Anna or without you know
baptism they they uh they did not
believe that you should baptize infants
because
>> baptism comes after salvific faith. So
when you believe God then you act in
obedience to him motivated by faith and
it's the faith that saves you.
>> But it's a it's an active faith that
works by obedience and love. And so to
place the work before the salvific faith
and suggest that that somehow provides
any salvific merit, you're putting them
the works ahead of the faith.
>> Yeah. So it might be helpful to
understand why
um Catholics were baptizing infants.
>> And that goes back to original sin
>> and when they believed that um you know
all human beings they're born they're
born sinful. And so if that infant were
to die before they were baptized,
imagine this is a terrible marketing
campaign, but if they were to die before
they're baptized, they go to hell.
>> Mhm.
>> So the solution to that is infant
baptism. And and of course that, you
know, you think about, well, why
sprinkle them? Well, dunking a baby
underwater, as you can imagine,
>> would create lots of problems. You don't
also want to drown the baby, right? They
hold their breath well.
>> They They probably do, but you can see
how like because of our own like, well,
we don't want to risk that and we
believe this and you see how things get
twisted and muddled and and all of that.
So, that's why they were baptizing
infants is because they believed, well,
they're they're going to go to hell if
we don't baptize them.
>> But that process cheapens the entire
context of the baptism and turns it into
a ritual. And then it's like if that was
the answer to salvation, you're
basically doing that activity. So it's
not the baby saying, "I want to do
this." It's you that's choosing that.
Why wouldn't you do that for everybody?
And then and then everybody's saved.
>> And you you have to I mean, you have to
wonder in in and I don't know this, but
you wonder in the church's mind, does
this make them look better because
they're trying to save as many as
possible,
>> right? Mhm.
>> Well, you know, so there were there were
obviously some differences here between
what they believed and what Rome
believed.
>> Yeah, absolutely.
>> And you know, there's other evidences
around the time period that Sylvester,
you know, what they're pointing back to
is this split. There was evidence that
from Revenous Mars that the same pope
decreed that the rest of the Sabbath
should be transferred rather to the
Lord's day in order that on that day we
should rest from worldly works for the
praise of God. So you see this kind of
like discussion around the same
historical period over the Sabbath and I
think we'll see that reflected in some
of the Walden sees uh you know some of
the evidences surrounding them as well.
But you know we began here by discussing
the woman that fled into the wilderness
in the context of Bible prophecy in
Revelation 12:6. The Walden Sea
historians stated that the vood
descended from those refugees from Italy
who after St. Paul had there preached
the gospel, abandoned their beautiful
country, and fled like the woman
mentioned in the apocalypse to these
wild mountains where they have to this
day handed down the gospel from father
to son in the same purity and simplicity
as it was preached by St. Paul.
>> Wow.
>> It's quite a claim.
>> I I actually the first time I heard
about the voodoo and about the Waldenes
was when I read the book The Great
Controversy. Mhm.
>> And um I I remember there was a segment
in there that talked about how they
would sew pages of the Bible into their
coats and they would send their children
off to bigger cities because they lived
in the mountains
>> to um you know
>> yeah to to see if anybody was perhaps
willing or wanting to know the truth and
they would show them because there was
no Bible back then in people's own
language. The Waldenes translated it,
right?
>> But other people had no access to it.
you have to go up to a priest or to a I
don't know a higher up a bishop maybe to
say like hey what does it mean and
they're like well here it is I'll read
Latin you don't understand Latin there's
those right it's called the dark ages
>> but yeah it really interesting how they
were such pious people and they knew
that they were they were
>> um um risking their lives doing this
they got busted they would be killed but
I do want to mention quickly for people
that want the great controversy we can
put a link in the description you can
read it for yourself it's a historical
book quoting other historicists about
what happened during the dark ages and
also how all this connects to Bible
prophecy in Revelation 13. Last time we
did this and we put a link in lots of
people wanted the book. People tell us,
"Hey, I I really wanted a book and it
was awesome." So, link in the
description for a free book.
>> So, the Valdenzians had to learn Latin,
right? So, they could read it because it
wasn't in their language at anybody's
language at that point, right?
>> Well, so they had a couple of different
languages going on. Um there's actually
they have we have some Bibles uh from
theirs in French and in Acatan. There's
a couple of different languages that
they used. But Rome was particularly
concerned and we can see evidence of
some of the decrees about the Bible
being in the vernacular at all. So they
had um they had a you know some of the
received text that they had passed down
and we I'll actually got some slides
coming up on that. So we'll take a look
at that here in just a moment. Um, one
of the things though it's important to,
you know, in the context of Revelation
12, this woman that fled into the
wilderness, there was a dragon that went
after her
>> and some of the crests, so the the
insignas of some of the papal armies
that went after these people actually
had the dragon featured on it.
>> And so there's another interesting
resource here for those of you who've
never seen it, Keepers of the Flame.
It's available on YouTube. But um here's
an excerpt of some of the persecution
that these people faced.
>> At the beginning of the 14th century,
the terrible fury of the pope's
inquisitors began.
The simple peaceloving waldenes became
part of the church in the wilderness as
foretold by John the Revelator.
But just as the woman of Revelation 12
was helped by the earth, which opened up
its mouth and swallowed the waters of
the dragon, so the mountains gave
protection to the waldenes during the
crusades against them.
[Music]
So we got to go back to the beginning
though. So how did this all begin? And I
think the way to start though is
actually, you know, there's evidence in
the Bible about Paul actually traveling
to Spain.
>> Mhm.
>> And you can find extra biblical evidence
as well in meritorian
cannon. Moreover, the acts of all the
apostles were written in one book, Acts.
For the most excellent Theophilus Luke
compiled the individual events that took
place in his presence as he plainly
shows by omitting the martyrdom of Peter
as well as the departure of Paul from
the city of Rome when he journeyed to
Spain. Now you know here's Romans 15:4.
Whsoever I take my journey into Spain I
will come to you for I trust to see you
in my journey. So we see evidence of
Paul you know he clearly went to Spain.
Even Clement talks about after preaching
both in the east and the west, he gained
the illustrious reputation due to his
faith. Uh having taught righteousness to
the whole world and come to the extreme
limit of the west. And you know over in
Spain there's actually a city called
Sabadel and it's it's in close to
Barcelona. You can see evidence of of or
a map here of where that's at. So if you
think about where Paul might have gone
from Rome up through perhaps the Alps
and all the way over to Barcelona,
there's actually a city there uh
district where there were some Sabbathke
keepers or thought to be Sabbath keepers
in the city of Sabadel.
And where did he pass through? He passed
through directly some of the regions
where they sprung up.
>> Mhm. In the early days, there's evidence
of people who held to some of their
beliefs in the districts of Rome.
Gregory the testifies to these
individuals, calling them, you know,
Antichrist, forbidding any work to be
done on the Sabbath day. But as
persecution ramped up in Rome, it's easy
to see how these people might have fled
to a safer region. And I think one of
the reasons for that being you can find
evidence of what happened. There was a
story account in this book Popery Pusis
and Jesuitism
um that there was a Waldenian who said
that the beautiful monuments of
ecclesiast and u antiquity
these rough materials are the ruins of
the two great palatine libraries one
Greek and the other Latin were the
precious manuscripts of our ancestors
were collected in which Pope Gregory I
called the great cause to be burned. So
there was papal persecution taking
place, books getting burned, people
being persecuted, and it was time to
flee to the mountains. And there's
evidence of some of these people holding
to the beliefs. Have you guys ever heard
of vigilanteas before?
>> Mhm.
>> Okay. So some of the things that he
opposed was reverence of relics, prayers
for the dead, sending alms to Jerusalem
instead of helping the poor, and the
exaggerated estimate of virginity. He
actually accused Jerome of being
infected with origin philosophy. But the
sad reality is is if Jerome you know had
listened to him, had only listened to
him, perhaps he might not have had to
leave Rome in disgrace and under
suspicion of allegations of you know
sexual impropriy perhaps with Lady Paula
and you know he was actually compelled
to leave Rome. He was very much acetic
in his positions and did not believe in
marriage of the clergy. And as a result,
you know, the disagreement with him and
vigilanteas, he failed to learn on
principle from vigilante.
>> H,
>> you know, what does Timothy talk about?
I mean, in the Bible,
>> the bishop shall be a husband of one
wife. It it advocates marriage, right?
>> There was a lot of sexual immorality
back then. Well,
I I guess I've never really to tr truly
fully understood why why are they so
against marriage because I think it's
going to be a distraction to you as a
priest.
>> Well, there's a lot that could be traced
back there intonosticism itself.
>> Whoa.
>> Yeah. Um you knownosticism actually had
a lot of influence on some of the
aceticism and um it was associated
actually with with some of the cults to
not actually be married like and and
Rome took that position too in in some
of her works that it was actually um
better to delay marriage a great deal
than to actually get married or in some
cases you know some of the statements
not get married at all. That was her
position. M
>> so
um the wild seas were very much opposed
to that obviously going back and and
supporting the creation concept that God
established at creation marriage was an
institution at creation along with the
Sabbath
>> right he he he actually said go be
fruitful right
>> exactly
>> and and and marriage is the refinement
of the character
>> so you know perhaps that was was kind of
influenced Satan knew he could have his
way with this group of people if it's
like you not you don't have that other's
focused and and you can see in the
church the selfishness that brood to the
point of pure per pure corruption so
interesting
>> Christ himself as our example
>> you know has throughout scripture this
parable of you know Matthew 22 and 25
you have this concept of a marriage
feast or a wedding feast right as he
marries his church
>> and the test over wedding garment and
all of that
>> marriage is upheld biblically Mhm.
>> It's an example given to us by Christ.
>> Mhm.
>> And so between these two individuals, I
would choose vigilanteas in his
positions because I believe that they
agree with the Bible.
>> Mhm.
>> But um you know, as history goes on
throughout the centuries, we see
evidence here at the Council of Fry
again long before the Waldenses that the
other twin institution at creation, the
Sabbath, was upheld. The peasants
observe this. And even Catholic scholars
like this one, Ysef on Heale said that
the farmers often celebrated on
Saturday. So there was evidence of
Sabbathkeeping
going through the centuries long before
we get to the times of Peter Waldo.
There was also Claude of Trin who was
another bishop uh around the 9th century
and uh he taught actually in 10th
century there was also Edbert and
Theophilact that a man is justified by
faith without any merit being attached
to his own works. He actually opposed
relics, images and crosses and had them
torn down as idols. And he made it clear
that sins were to be forgiven apart from
the merit of works. and he taught to
abolish the merit of human works and
uplift the grace of God.
>> Which year was that?
>> You're looking at the 9th century here.
>> And actually found some of his works on
the Vatican digital library
reggg.lat.998.
>> So is that an early form of crossword
puzzle?
>> Um that's a good question
>> or a word search.
>> Yeah. So I haven't gone through all
>> Is that an actual document or is it just
somebody's artistic interpretation?
>> No, that's actually uh it's it's an
actual document. This is not AI right
here, but you can find that on uh on
Google.
>> And a lot of those, you know, like Greek
didn't have any punctuation. So,
>> was it just evenly spaced like that?
>> Um,
>> so it just looks like a block of letters
>> evenly spaced, but it it at least
originally it would have been hard to,
you know, untrained eye it be harder to
because you're like, "Oh, that's a word
there and then this is the next word."
>> So, they would practice with the
crossword puzzle here.
Yeah. So, one of the oldest Waldenzian
documents that survives uh today is
actually the Noblon.
And this is a document available from
Trinity College in Dublin, Ireland. It's
MS261.
It uh has a poem about kind of the
Waldenzy story from the time of the
apostles. And one of the statements that
we read from it is now after the
apostles were certain teachers who
taught the way of Jesus Christ our
savior. And these are found even at this
present day. If any man love those who
are good, he must needs love God and
Jesus Christ. Such a one will neither
curse nor swear nor lie. Now such a one
is termed a Waldenzian and worthy to be
punished. For I dare say it is very true
that all the popes which have been from
Sylvester to this present and all
cardinals, bishops and abbotts and like
have no power to absolve or pardon.
>> So we find some evidence that you know
kind of reckons back to the antiquity.
Have you guys ever seen their school
before over in Italy?
>> Wasn't this in the Keepers of the Flame?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, I watched it. Yeah,
>> we should put a link in the description
for that series, too. It's awesome.
>> Yeah. So, they went to the mountains and
established schools. And do you guys
know what their teachers were called?
>> I don't remember.
>> Barbs.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. Barbs. And so Barb actually meant
uncle instead of father.
>> Why would they do that? The Bible says
you shall not call anyone father.
>> Yeah.
>> So this is a title of authority, right?
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So it was it was a way to
respectfully refer to their teacher but
not violate the scriptural command and
suggest that this person is, you know,
your spiritual father like taking away
the position of of Christ.
>> It it's interesting because I actually
have thought about that verse that says
that and it just popped in my head like
well well I mean obviously it cannot
mean that you can't call your biological
father because that doesn't make sense.
people call Godfather and stuff which
which it allows for in that verse but
>> but so what you explained to me before
we started filming is that this means
like like like I said earlier it's a
title of authority not like a biological
or you know referencing someone as a
loving father figure or anything but
it's like father so and so uh you are a
priest or whatever and you're the
authoritative power that's what it means
right so Rome uses the title father in
very much an authoritative sense in a
blasphe
of of you know referring to the
characteristics of the individual but
referring to that seat of authority and
that's the that's the problem right
there is um and of course all the other
decrees where they have taught that they
are you know vicarious or actually a
substitute for Christ so they obviously
taking it to that point where it's
blasphemy
>> so for those of you who are interested
actually one of the best books that that
I found that talks about the history of
the wild
talks about the massacres and the the
persecution they faced with Samuel
Morland's. This one's from 1658.
>> That's a pope.
>> Uh no, that's actually Samuel Morland, a
>> Is he Waldenian?
>> Uh no, he was a Protestant who spoke
with one of the Waldenzian ministers by
the name of John Leger and collected a
lot of manuscripts from him. And those
manuscripts are now available in the
libraries of Trinity College in
Cambridge. And Trinity has done some
really good work digitizing all of
theirs. Cambridge is still sitting on
their collection and Cambridge wants a
lot of money for them to digitize them.
So, um
>> yeah, they're they're in the unpublished
manuscripts DD3.25
um with Cambridge, but this work has a
lot of images of some of the persecution
they faced and I've kind of blurred some
of these out a little bit because
they're quite violent and there's a lot
of gore there,
>> but these people faced severe
persecution.
>> So, um
>> wild.
>> Yeah. One of the things though, you
know, let's talk about the character of
these people. For those of you watching
today, how well do you know your Bible?
Because these people, the third cause of
heresy according to Reerius Sako is that
they've translated the new and old
testament into the vulgar tongue. So
into the common tongue, and thus they
teach and learn. And I have seen and
heard a certain lay countryman who
repeated the book of Job word for word.
>> And many knew perfectly knew the whole
New Testament.
>> Wow,
>> that's impressive. So, I have a theory
on this. They didn't have social media.
>> They didn't have TV,
>> right?
>> You went to bed when the lights went
down.
>> And it's like you had you had this was
your form of of entertainment and and
itching your mind. You know,
>> well, and it's also just they just had a
genuine desire to have a relationship
with Jesus.
>> You know, by beholding, we become
changed. The more we behold the word of
God, the more we'll be changed. And
Revelation 3 talks about the well two
and three actually talks about the seven
churches that many u biblical scholars
from several denominations believe are
were both historical churches in the
timeline and also um um
>> metaphoric
>> metaphorical. Yeah. And so we are
technically a metaphorical
>> uh metaphorically we are uh leodysian
which means that we are actually
lukewarm Christians and we need to get
come out of that. We need to be revived
and and get in the word and and for
those who want to get in the word,
lls.tv/bible
school and you can learn all about this
prophecy stuff right there. Yeah. You
know, they've there were some there were
several groups obviously some uh
albaenses, you've got some Waldenes,
they're often talked about side by side.
Some of the precursors or some people
think that the Cathars are precursors of
the albenses.
You know, I think it's interesting that
as far as eating meat, eggs, or cheese,
they thought it was a mortal sin. They
did not indulge in that in the Cathars.
>> Did they get that from Daniel 1?
>> So, that's a that's a question for
debate there. You know, some people will
say no. Uh some people will, you know,
talk about the different reasons why
they believed in that. Um, as far as I
think, you know, us today, we have clear
biblical evidence in in Daniel 1. And
whether or not they argued that, there's
only actually one Cathar book that
survived the flames of the Inquisition
>> and it's the book of the two principles.
So there's a lot that we don't know
about these people because when you go
burning a bunch of books, you destroy
evidence of fact of what they actually
believed and you're left with a lot of
people slinging accusations
>> but not a lot of solid evidence
>> about what the reasons why they chose to
do that.
>> God has always worked with his people in
in a health capacity, right? brings the
children of Israel out of the land of
Egypt who are desiring everything in the
flesh pot
>> and God gives them mana
>> and is like, you know, there's the food
for you right there. It's like he could
have easily just made cattle walk
through the camp every day, right? But
he didn't. And and so, you know, I think
the to see that line through different,
you know, groups that have really been
connected to God is kind of cool.
>> Yeah. I kind of wonder if they also were
looking at what was happening in the
priesthood and saying, "Look, these guys
are eating a lot of rich foods
>> and and saying we don't we don't want to
espouse the same thing."
>> And so they just chose it's a simpler
diet. You know, here's a evidence of
what they believed about the gospel.
This is actually from the pros from John
Leger over in Trinity. The fourth thing
is that to do that which is profitable
to the soul as to think on God devoutly,
to pray to him diligently, to hear his
commandments and his holy doctrine, to
give so the commandments of God, right?
And the faith of Jesus,
>> Revelation 14, right?
>> Uh to give thanks to God and all his
benefits, to instruct the ignorant, to
correct the erroneous, and to preserve
ourselves from all sin. to that end that
saying of EA may be accomplished, cease
to do evil, learn to do well, for the
rest is not good, if it not be
accompanied with good works.
>> They believed in overcoming
>> that God can work in you
>> and help you to overcome all sin.
>> That's a
>> to make sense.
>> Yeah, that's a controversial gospel
these days, but
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> But it's true.
>> Yeah, there's a lot of church.
>> I mean, it's in the Bible. Jesus Jesus
said be therefore perfect even as your
father as your father in heaven is
perfect. We can do it. He can do it
through us.
>> You brought up the seven churches. Um to
him that overcomes I will grant him to
sit on my throne. And each one of the
churches has that particular word.
>> Y
>> so we know that even throughout time if
it is a physical real timeline of of
churches that the same thing was asked
of
>> and and Jesus said sin not. Exactly.
>> Don't continue in sin. It's just flu.
The Bible is chalk full of these verses.
>> We're not saying it's easy.
>> No. But
>> this is this is the most difficult thing
to overcome things that you struggle
with. Yes.
>> But here's the thing. If we say I cannot
overcome sin, we're saying Satan, a
created being, a fallen angel, is
stronger than God to keep us in sin than
God to save us from sin.
>> And that's actually his argument. Yeah.
That's actually Satan's argument against
God is saying like, "Hey, these people
are doing nothing different than what I
did. I sinned and they never turned
around. And so he's trying to make that
accusation against us where God is
giving us mercy and grace and helping
us, you know, overcome those things.
>> I think of Job 122. In all this, Job
sinned not nor charge God foolishly.
>> Yeah. And we have a whole video on this
too that uh you guys should check out.
>> And and and that's an interesting point
because you you can see that probably
Satan's accusation against God or what
he's trying to achieve is this whole
planet is on my side.
>> Like leave us alone. were all on my side
and God's going, "Nope, I I got I got
one right here. I got one right here."
>> Yep.
>> It It's It's bad when you know the worst
accusation you can come up against
somebody or or one of them is heretics
are distinguished by their manners and
their words, for they are sedate and
modest in their manners. They have no
pride in clothes, for they wear such as
neither costly nor mean. They do not
carry on business in order to avoid
falsehoods, oaths, and frauds, but only
live by labor as workmen. Their teachers
are shoemakers and weavers. They're also
temperate in meat and drink. They go not
to taverns, dances, or other vanities.
They restrain themselves from anger.
They're always at work, learning,
teaching, and so they pray but little.
>> Oh, wait.
>> No, they pray a lot.
>> They obey, right? Oh, yeah.
>> They obey. They're not going and like
praying, okay, I'm going to go pray 10
hours a day and then, you know, 5 hours
I'm going to go cheat over here and and
make up the money that I need in that
short amount of time and look at my, you
know, Christianity that's so pious or
whatever.
>> So, they pray little because they are
mostly on a a obedient path.
>> Yeah, they're they're obeying. Um,
>> interesting what it says after that
also. They go hypocritically to church,
offer and make confession and
communicate, and they go to sermons. But
it is that they may
>> catch the preacher in his discourse. In
other words, we don't want to be tr
taught heresy. So, we're watching you,
buddy. Like, you're the one teaching the
Bible. We know the Bible.
>> Yeah. I mean, you know, I almost wish
there was a little bit more of that. It
would probably be pretty disrupting to a
lot of churches. But,
>> um, you know, if people really
factchecked the pastors, I I highly
doubt when pastors start throwing Bible
texts out there that are kind of taken
out of context, how many go home and
actually look that up? Mhm.
>> It says they may be known by their
precision and moderation of their
language. So they were they watched what
they said. They were careful about it.
And uh so how did they go about though
sharing the gospel door to door? One of
the things that they did is they went
and sold merchandise, sold different
things, and they used that as their hook
to kind of get in the door to be able to
share somebody the gospel and the love
of Jesus. And you know, I think about
that. You made a point earlier about how
these folks might have been the original
uh little light folks, right?
>> They were they were shining light in the
darkness.
>> Their maxim was literally like loose
lucid inbbras which light shines in
darkness. I mean
>> expose the darkness.
>> Exactly.
>> It's funny.
>> So
I mean it really boils down to I think
what what every single one of us is
supposed to be about, right? If if we're
YouTubers, our purpose is to bring
people to Jesus. If you're a doctor, the
purpose would be to to help in in a um
physical sense, but also to point people
back to God. And no matter what your
discipline is, no matter what your job
function is, you can be a software
engineer, whatever. If you thought in
your mind, this is my vehicle to get in
the door so I can share the truth.
>> I think we'd see a radically changed
world.
So over the years there's been a debate
about this group of people because the
Presbyterians or the Calvinists have
wanted to claim these people as their
antiquity. A lot of people have
recognized the piety, the modesty, the
truth that these people had and wanted
to claim them as, well, these are my
spiritual ancestors.
>> The Calvinists and the Presbyterians
have tried to do that. But let's take a
look and see what the evidence actually
indicates about infant baptism a little
bit more because we talked about that
>> and you know Epherinus of Stanfield in
Cologne uh writing to St. Bernard in
1140 they do not hold the baptism of
infants alleging the passage of the
gospel. He that believeth and is
baptized shall be saved. Going on to
Tuloise canon 3 regarding the heretics
from the church of God which we condemn
under assemblance of religion deny the
sacrament of the Lord's body
transubstantiation the baptism of
children the priesthood and other
ecclesiastical orders going on Bernard
Gi in his inquis inquisition of Tuloise
that baptism of water administered by
the church is of no use to children
because the children so far from giving
a scent to it cried at it. What a
pitiful situation. And here's this child
crying like they're not they don't want
to go along.
>> It's not joyful for them.
>> Yeah. Here we see another evidence right
here uh Diodwinus talking about how as
far as them lives uh as in them lies
overthrow the baptism of infants. And
even the Jesuit Cardinal Bellerin
himself spoke of one of their pastors,
Barangarius taught not to baptize little
ones. And it may well be said of the
Anabaptists. So he himself, even the
Catholic Jesuit cardinal Bellerin
himself is connecting Baronarius, a
welding minister with the Anabaptists.
>> You wonder as a as a as a reason why
Satan would want this to happen because
were they ever rebaptized?
>> Uh in some cases, yes.
>> But it was probably not common. Well, in
some cases there were some who went I
have seen evidence of some who would who
would go along um with baptism like if
they were forced in a certain situation
but then later on would go back and
actually baptize uh when they again when
they had
>> when they intellectually made the choice
at that point. Yeah. Because if if this
was a way to pacify you like oh I'm
already baptized I don't need to do that
again. think about like there's a lot of
complex reasons why you wouldn't want to
do that at that stage
>> and then you know teenagers are probably
the same today as they were yesterday.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, Jacob Gretzer, once again,
another evidence here. Baptism given to
infants profits nothing. Nihil prophet.
>> So, for those of you who are interested
in actually what they said themselves on
the matter, I found a while back a
manuscript that has all of the catalog
of documents from Trinity. And you can
look up the manuscripts by their folio
or their numbers here. 269, 270, 262.
These are all of the pros tracks. So,
we're going to take a look at some of
the evidence from their own writings on
the matter. And they said right here in
MS267 that the third work of Antichrist
consists that he attributes the
regeneration of the Holy Spirit unto the
dead outward work baptizing infants in
that faith.
>> So, they called it a work of antichrist
>> to baptize infants. I mean, that's solid
right there that they're Anabaptists.
Yeah,
>> for sure. Now some people have argued
you know what did they believe about
religious liberty? They said that the
seventh work of antichrist is that he
doth not govern nor maintain his unity
by the holy spirit but by the secular
power and maketh use thereof to affect
spiritual matters.
>> So he's not being guided by the holy
spirit. He's he's tapping into the
world.
>> This is inconsistent with you know John
Calvin and burning cberus. This is this
is very much consistent with maybe Roger
Williams that we see later on upholding
religious liberty and freedom along the
baptis you know the Baptists line of
thinking as opposed to the
Presbyterians.
Now there was some stuff that changed
later on when they got wiped out. But
let's take a look at some of their views
on Bible prophecy. The fourth iniquity
of Antichrist is that notwithstanding as
being the fourth beast formerly
described by Daniel in the of the
revelation.
Now that's reflected even by the
inquisitors who said they say that the
Roman church is the church of the
wicked, the beast and the harlot which
are described in the apocalypse.
Hm.
>> So they identified I mean this is not
this is not consistent with the Walden
sees of today who are welcoming Pope
Francis in and saying okay you know
>> we're on the same side
>> that that document that you showed last
time you were on here with all of the
reformers and everybody that believed
the pope was the antichrist. And I think
it was everyone. I don't I don't think
there was even one that was like nah
maybe that's like wrong. They all agreed
on that.
>> Yeah. And we should add to that, not the
pope as in the individual and once he
dies there's no longer an antichrist.
It's the the the position of the papacy
of being a pope that we're talking
about.
>> Good clarification.
>> Um and then um also it's interesting
that they're saying here that they're
connecting that the harlot in
Revelation, the beast in Revelation are
all the same
>> entity as well as the antichrist.
They're all the same cuz some people say
like the antichrist is this, but like
they have no clue what the beast is
actually. It's all the same entity. It's
all the papacy.
>> So, you know, uh there they were called
by many different names. You've got the
patines. You've got the tulipans. You've
got the uh Pasagans.
And one of the things that we find in
these this number is that they were
called in Sabati as well because of
Sabbathkeeping. You can see evidence in
the Vatican digital library of this
inquisitor right here, Moneta of
Cremona, who said, "Why shall not the
church give up her time on the Lord's
day to attend to the gospel which leads
to perfection? Against this, the heretic
objects, namely the Catherite and the
wildens, which is found in Galatians
4:10." So, they objected to Rome
establishing Sunday. Okay. And there's
another actually individual from the
same time period, Preposentinus of
Cremona, who said to the above the
aforeset heretics add concerning the
observance of the Sabbath to prove which
they lean in this way. And of course,
you know, we've got Bonursus as well,
the Pasagini that the Sabbath is still
being in force. Um there's multiple
documents that establish this. You've
got another work against the manacheans,
the heretics of pasagos, uh that they
kept the Sabbath literally.
And even the Jesuit inquisitor Francis
Pegnney said that many used to think
insabati came from Sabbath and that they
observed the Sabbath according to the
custom of the Jews.
>> So it's like this was a flag, if you
will, of obedience to the law of God
that's carried throughout the centuries
by these individuals. And there's been
some people over the years that have
said, "Ah, they didn't, you know, they
didn't keep the Sabbath." There's not
evidence of that. But I think what
they're doing is paying attention to
some of the works uh and influence that
crept in later on by the Presbyterian
side and the reformers who were still in
many cases, you know, not connected with
this faith that was reaching back to the
time of the apostles and had not fully
reformed yet.
>> It was a pro process really. um the
reformation.
>> I remember something that stuck with me
when we had Scott Ritzma on the the
channel and he's a history teacher so
you know he's he's he's used to looking
at things in a timeline and he said
actually it's it's more or less like a
like almost like a circle and they kind
of in intersect in certain spots as if
like different groups are dealing with
the same thing but they could be
centuries apart. You know what I mean?
>> And it's like you can see the parallel
right here. the persecution, making a
stand for what you believe is about that
day and all these things. You're you're
seeing almost the exact same similar
situation that we we are are going to
experience in the very end of time.
>> Yeah. It's almost like, you know, um not
all who say they are of Abraham or
Abraham's seed, right? It's those who
actually have the faith of Abraham. It
doesn't matter if you have a direct
father-to- lineage,
>> right?
>> You know, it matters if you obey and
have the same faith. Matthew 7, you
know, not everybody calls them says,
"Lord, Lord, shall be saved." Because
there's people who say, "I love Jesus,
and Lord, didn't I do all these things
in your name, cast out demons, all these
things, and Jesus said, I don't know
you."
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, there's a lot more
evidence that they kept the Sabbath.
You've got even Catholic priests who
testified to that. But um you know one
of the things that they were called is
sometimes they were called Waldenzians
but sometimes Petro Bruscians because
Peter Bruis who came right after Peter
Waldo you know came and did a lot of
evangelical work and they were called by
the different names of their ministers
even though it was all kind of the same
body but the Petrusians
they were condemned among other things
because they kept the Sabbath and even
opponents of the Sabbath right here for
for example this is Dr. Francis White in
1636 talked about how it was condemned
in the Petroians.
There's more evidence that they actually
kept it uh and reverenced it.
>> That would be weird, I think, to have
people named after you like, you know,
the Baptist or the Calvinist or
whatever, like the Scottians.
>> Yeah.
>> Like I don't know. I don't I don't think
I I would want that at all.
>> So, you know, here's Mel Gurgle. Not
because they were circumcised but
because they kept the Jewish Sabbath
where they called insabati.
And we find evidence from some of the
persecutors of them. Claudius Kusard
wrote that on holidays where they can
secretly they work arguing that it is
good when they work. It is not bad to
bond or work on a holiday. So they would
work on like a Sunday and they would try
and do it secretly so that they didn't
give offense
>> but they didn't they didn't regard the
day at all. And you know, we talked
earlier about all their different names.
The Pasagans, the Troplans, the In
Sabati. Here's another name. The Tropins
upheld that the Saturday must be
celebrated instead of the Sunday. And we
can find evidence of some martyrs,
Gilbert Tulin and Simon Beckuit, who
actually were killed as a result of
that. Here is the inquisitor Heinrich
Kramer who said that it is a matter of
their blindness over the change of the
Sabbath with that they do not recognize
the authority of the Roman and Apostolic
Church. So to them this was a matter of
whose authority you accept
>> which is really what the argument at the
end with the seal of God is whose
authority are you taking? Are you taking
Satan's Satan's authority? Are you
taking God? and and yeah, it's like the
pope was really just like, if you don't
worship on the day I'm telling you to
worship on, then you're not agreeing
with me.
>> So, there was a lot of push back for
this, no doubt. And it's interesting
here you have an example of how they
were portrayed in some of the cartoons
of the day. Yeah. Here's the voodoois
right here, the voa. They were portrayed
as witches flying around on broomsticks.
Even though when they would reach out to
the king, here's an example of what they
would write. It to the most serene and
most high prince, uh, Filibbert Emanuel,
Duke of Savo, Prince of Pedmont, our
most gracious lord. They would write in
a very, very respectful manner. And they
were polite. They treated, you know,
those who disagreed with them with the
grace of Christ.
>> I mean, that's a lesson for us today.
Mhm.
>> But also understanding where prophecy is
headed and where we are headed very
soon. I believe Revelation 13, this is
going to happen again where Christians
will be um genuine Christians will be
persecuted, will be written off as all
kinds of things and you're all of this
and that and God's like those are my
people and the people who are
persecuting them are like calling them
labeling them all kinds of things. And
then it's, you know, again, Matthew 7,
but also understanding Revelation 13, a
lot of the people who will persecute
God's remnant people are going to call
themselves Christians
>> just like in here, right? They're like,
"We are the true church, the mother
church, and we have the truth, whereas
they were completely deceived." And the
Baldenes who had the truth were labeled
as witches.
>> Yeah. But the attitude of the people is
is significant.
>> Yeah. you know, being kind and loving
and and still being respectful in in all
things. I remember reading a reading or
hearing a story a long time ago of a
family that was brought before the king
because they were found to be in a
disobedience of the land based on some
religious things. And they were very
respectful, very, you know, kind. They
would related to the king that they were
loyal subjects. They prayed for him like
twice a day and all these kind of
things. And the king let them go because
he was surprised at the character of the
people. He thought they were just, you
know, these heretics like everybody was
saying. And you get the idea that,
>> you know, unfortunately we try
society, we demonize other people,
>> you know, who don't disagree with us.
You see it in like politics all the
time, right? Both sides,
>> you know, want to make the other side
out to be, you know, the worst when
they're really not. But if they live in
the mountains and they're wanting to
live their life like they believe and
feel convicted for following Jesus all
the way, well all in, right? What does
the big organization in the valley care?
I mean, why are you going up there and
and wanting to take them out? I can
understand if they're like running down
into the towns and burning things or
causing havoc. Okay, I get I get the
response. But if you're out over here
living your life like whatever, what's
the purpose of trying to go out and just
wipe them all out?
>> Yeah. There's Well,
>> you're a standing rebuke.
>> Well, one, power.
>> Mhm.
>> And and two, money.
>> Yep.
>> Wait. So, describe the money.
>> Well, if if you're persuading people
that this is not the power you should be
following,
>> so they're not giving to the church now.
>> Tithes, offerings, all that kind of
stuff, it's not going there. So you're
hitting them where it hurts. Huh?
>> Pocketbook.
>> And you know, certain people just they
like to be in charge of other people.
They crave that that power.
>> Yeah. You know, scripture says, "Honor
all men, love the brotherhood, fear God,
honor the king."
>> 1 Peter 21:17.
>> And that's what they did. Um, but they
faced a lot of persecution. And here's
some of the interesting rules of caution
whereby the inquisitors regulated the
prosecution of them. They said it is not
expedient to dispute concerning matters
of faith before layman. Uh they would
they would talk about you know how they
they ought to be very careful uh don't
permit him to excuse himself or to
declare his innocence before the people
for if such a one be put to death it
scandalizes the layman and if he escape
it becomes a prejudice to our religion.
So they had all of these these rules
that go on about, you know, don't allow
him to declare his innocence. And
there's no hope of all of convincing
heretics by the knowledge of the
scriptures or learning for as much as
oftenimes it falls out that very learned
men are confounded by them.
>> That's right.
>> And by that means the heretics fortify
themselves and when they find that even
learned men themselves are deceived by
them. So nothing stands before the word
of God.
>> Right? M
>> like that is what they relied on and
that's the power
>> that that fueled them.
Uh heretics must never be suffered to
answer directly to anything and when
they are pressed by frequent
interrogatives they have a custom to
make an answer that they are poor
ignorant men. It sounds to me like they
were humble.
>> Mhm.
>> And that they would also at times not
answer. Didn't Christ himself when he
was standing before Pilot?
>> Sheep before this sheer
>> Yeah. is dumb.
>> Exactly. But they you can you can see
they they kind of knew what they were
dealing with. They knew their opponent
and and they knew like Yeah, they appear
like they're they're humble, ignorant
men, but they're not.
>> Yeah.
>> They're a lot smarter than than we're
giving them credit for because they're
confounding some of our people.
>> Yeah. So, you know, ultimately they
faced a lot of persecution and one of
the ways that they were persecuted was
they couldn't buy or sell.
>> Revelation 13, everybody. Yep. See what
I mean by the circles?
>> Yeah.
>> That you actually kind of have these
different things that are happening with
the different groups
>> and and it's almost like we're we're all
told like the kingdom of heaven is at
hand. Repent, right? Do all these things
that you know Jesus is at the door.
Well, he really is kind of if you just
look at it like in those different terms
for those people, it's almost the same
time frame as what we're experiencing.
You know what I mean?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So it was not just the
senote of tours but the council of tour
uh lyan as well under Alexander III
prohibiting buying and selling and you
know they there were times where they
were persecuted heavily and almost like
the children of Israel there were almost
repeats of some of those biblical
stories. There was an account of one
like almost David and Goliath story
>> where this this um Pedmont guard
one of the surnamed the black of Mondovi
actually came up with bravado and there
was a young uh young man of Enrania
named Peter Rall who struck this new
Goliath with a steel-ointed arrow with
such violence that it penetrated into
his skull between his eyes and laid him
dead and he came up and you know was
boasting and bragging very much like
Goliath himself and it was a it was a a
youth who actually you know defended
their village by um responding to this
one warrior. It was a tale that was told
and retold but
>> why they call it a bullseye.
[Laughter]
>> Yeah. So as a result the same thing
happened what happened with ancient
Israel where the voodoo actually took
pursuit at that moment and the papal
guards ran and just fled. M
>> so it was the same thing as like what
happened with the Philistines.
>> Now ultimately there was some
persecution that took place here and
we'll take a look at this clip guys.
Take a look at Keepers of the Flame.
It's an incredible series.
>> Mhm.
>> In 1487, just 4 years after Luther's
birth, Pope Innocent VI determined to
purge the valleys of their inhabitants.
Promising those who joined the crusade
the remission of all their sins. He
proceeded to raise a large army under
the direction of Albert Katanio.
[Music]
Katanio camped his army at the foot of
the mighty Castelloo just near the
valley capital Toree.
Hoping to avert disaster, the Waldenzis
sent two of their number to meet with
him.
If the Waldenzes had hoped to intimidate
Katanio with their forthright approach,
they had sadly misjudged their man.
Dividing his forces in two, Katanio
directed one company to march up the
Peliche Valley, attacking the villages
of Villo and Bobio and forcing the
inhabitants to flee to the mountains.
the other company. He determined to lead
up the Androna Valley right to the Pra
Del Toronto where he expected to link up
with the others.
In his day, the road to the Pra was
nearly blocked by the barricade. This
was a steep rampart that crossed the
valley, its only entrance being a path
so narrow that barely two men could walk
it side by side. Today, it is wide
enough for motor traffic. Here
at Proud Del Toronto, the Waldenzis
assembled for one final stand. But
before they did, they committed
themselves to God in prayer.
>> Would an angel be sent to block the
invader's path? or would the flickering
flame of God's truth finally be
extinguished?
[Music]
As Katanio's army prepared to enter the
narrow pass, the Waldenzes noticed a
small cloud forming on the nearby
mountain peaks.
It rapidly grew larger and darker until
finally it tumbled down into the valley.
The dense fog caused immediate
confusion.
Being at an advantage in the changed
conditions, the Waldenzis climbed the
secret paths above the invaders and
began hurling large rocks on the
soldiers below.
In the ensuing panic, Katanio's forces
began to fight one another until
scarcely a man remained.
This is a copy right here of that death
decree that came against them by Pope
Innocent the 8. It's called Idnos Cortis
and it ordered the execution and
extermination of the same heretics.
Here's a copy from Trinity. I've also
got another copy with the seal at the
bottom. But this goes and provides
evidence that Rome was directly involved
in the shedding of the blood of these
individuals.
>> And Albert Katano came and led the
crusade up against them. You can see
right here in 1487 when this bull went
forth by Pope Innocent.
And there were individuals, there were
children that were torn from the arms of
their mothers. They were thrown over a
cliff.
>> There was another account of a um a cave
whereby they built a fire at the
entrance of it. And there were 3,000
individuals in those caves. About 400
infants were found in the stifled in the
arms of their mothers. And it was the
mountain was later nicknamed Chappelleu
for the great number of hats found
nearby on sticks from so many men who
were slain.
>> So they built the fire so the smoke
would go into the cave and suffocate
them.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow. You know, it it got so bad uh
following the massacre
uh especially in Pedmont that uh John
Milton wrote a poem where he said,
"Ovenge, O Lord, thy slaughtered saints,
whose bones lie scattered on the alpine
mountains cold, even them who kept the
truth so pure of old, when all our
fathers worship stocks and stones.
Forget not in thy book record their
groans, who were thy sheep and their
ancient fold. Slain by the bloody
pedmont montes that rolled mother with
infant down the rocks. Their moans the
veils were doubled to the hills and they
to heaven their martyed blood and ashes
so over the Italian fields where still
dust sway the triple tyrant that from
these may grow a hundfold who having
learned thy way early may fly the
Babylonian woe
>> Babylon
>> triple tyrant is he referring to the
triple crown.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> So um they faced tremendous persecution.
they were wiped out uh in many cases and
they started sending some of their
students over to Geneva to learn around
the the early 16th century and that's
where you start to see the influence of
Calvin into the the people that survived
>> and ultimately over time you see how the
movement has kind of fallen away today
to where now they're back with Rome and
and inviting the pope to come in.
>> But that's also part of Bible prophecy.
Yes. Its wound shall be healed. Mhm.
>> It's healing and they saw wonder. Yeah.
Wonder after the beast.
>> There is movements though that came out
that continued the faith of these people
and kept it alive. And we can see that
reflected in the Anabaptists. And you
know, we've talked about Arasmus before
on some of the other channel or videos
that um recognized a new type of Jews,
these sabotarians who observe the
Sabbath. and Andreas Fiser uh an early
Anabaptist minister in 1532 who who
continued some of the beliefs on the
Sabbath. There was actually even an
Anabaptist song in early 1530 u from
some of the the Baptist movements that
continued and we see that reflected
today where there are individuals there
are groups of Protestants who still
teach many of the ancient beliefs of
these people even though the modern
Waldenzians who go by that name no
longer hold to the beliefs of their
forefathers. Mhm.
>> To me, it's a it's an important lesson
that we ought not to be followers of
men.
>> Mhm.
>> But followers of the word of God that's
not going to lead us astray so that we
may remain of that faith of Abraham and
not be led astray into into apostasy.
>> Amen. Yeah. The Bible does say, "Let no
man deceive you."
>> Yeah.
>> You know, be on guard. Like you you
really should get your facts, your
information, and your connection through
the Bible.
>> Yeah. A pastor can can inspire you, but
it's it's it's not worth you throwing it
out for just trusting in implicitly in
everything that they say. Look it up.
Get that relationship for yourself and
and fact check those things.
>> Mhm. You got to get in the word. I mean,
the word is the only source of hope and
truth that we have in this life. And
people will deceive you. I mean, people
whom you think are the most um um
knowledgeable in the Bible might got it
all wrong. You have to study it for
yourself. That's what these people did.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and and I want to add to that again
um some really great resources, the
great controversy. Link in the
description for that.
>> Um
>> keepers of the flame.
>> Keepers of the flame. Link in the
description of that. And also watch our
video on uh what who is the antichrist?
James did the video where he showed you
how the pilgrims uh all believe the
pilgrims who came to America believed
that the that the antichrist was the
papacy. Um and watch our video on what
the mark of the beast is cuz the mark of
the beast will be um you know a part of
the antichrist system as well. So please
check those out for yourself and again
dig in scriptures, dig in a word.
>> And if you have any questions about any
of this material, you would probably be
the one to talk to. We'll put his his uh
how you can get a hold of him in the
description below and you can ask and
fire away as many questions as you want.
>> Check out James' channel, Biblical Hope.
>> Yeah, subscribe to this guy. He's got
gobs of this stuff and it's valuable. I
think it really is. And and to see where
these lines of truth, you know, have
have have trickled down through the
years, we're going to experience things
that that are similar.
>> Yeah. And also, your brother has a
channel where you appear as well called
uh Heritage and Hope Ministries or
Heritage and Hope on YouTube.
>> Yeah. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos.
>> And drop a comments below, and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
>> Say that again. No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]